investors don't believe the Federal
Reserve the FED has said they're going
to raise U.S interest rates by around
one percent and hold them there until at
least the end of 2023. investors are
saying nah how do we know that we know
by looking at the FED fund's Futures
Market I'm going to explain what the FED
fund's Futures Market is break down how
it shows that investors don't believe
the fed and explain why it matters to
the market and could have major
implications for the health of the U.S
economy let's get into it in order to
understand what investors expect from
the Federal Reserve you have to
understand the FED fund's Futures Market
fed fund's Futures are Financial Futures
contracts that are traded on the Chicago
Mercantile Exchange or the CME
historically the contracts were a way
for Traders to hedge their bets in case
of surprise rate changes by the FED but
today the market is mainly a way for
Traders to bet on where the FED will set
interest rates Traders make money if
they buy the contract of the lines with
the FED funds rate in a given month that
rate is set by the Federal Reserve at
meetings eight times a year on these
days
the 30-day contracts are listed for 60
consecutive months so we can see what
these traders of betting the FED will do
well into the future
the FED is repeated in meetings and at
press conferences that they plan to keep
rates High we continue to anticipate
that ongoing increases will be
appropriate in order to attain a stance
of monetary policy that is sufficiently
restrictive and they said in the most
recent summary of economic projections
that they expect to end 2023 with
interest rates set between 5.1 and 5.4
percent investors clearly don't believe
them we can see this with the cme's FED
watch tool it shows that based on the
buying and selling of fed fund's Futures
contracts Traders see less than a two
percent chance the rate will be where
the FED predicts at year end and we can
see that contracts purchased through the
end of the year show a 55 probability of
a rate of 4.5 percent or lower so why
does this matter to anyone other than
Futures Traders well fed funds Futures
are a reflection of Market sentiment and
if Market participants don't believe the
FED its policies are not as effective
interest rate increases are designed to
tighten Financial conditions which
essentially means keep bond yield tie Ai
and stock price is low but since Market
participants don't believe the FED will
keep raising rates stock prices have
been rising and bond yields have been
falling recently that could push the FED
to raise interest rates even higher or
hold them at higher levels for longer
and that could do more damage to the
real economy the fed's rate hikes in
2022 more than doubled the prime rate
which sets the floor for the interest
rate on personal and small business
loans it went from 3.25 in January to
7.5 percent in December If the Fed moves
rates even higher because Traders don't
believe them that will price more
consumers and companies out of the
market for loans and maybe price them
out of business a higher fed funds rate
also means higher interest rates for
things like credit cards and auto loans
and traditionally higher mortgage rates
as well this could mean increasingly
worse economic outcomes for just about
everyone for an increasingly long amount
of time
Brooklyn rapper code of the friend has
some wise words for times of uncertainty
he says fast money come and go I'd
rather take the slow route never judge
there's always something you don't know
about
that's all for now see you next time
[Music]